He does whatever a Spider can - but what about
body-swapping?
In an interview with Comics Explained, Spider-Man
actor Tom Holland revealed that he would love
for Peter Parker and Wolverine to team up
for a body swap movie.
Comics Explained asked Holland which Marvel
movie world outside of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe he would like to appear in, and Holland
had his answer at the ready, citing a 15-year-old
Ultimate Spider-Man storyline.
"Wolverine wakes up in Peter Parker's body,
and he, like, goes to school and all of a
sudden Peter Parker's like being this really
gross, rude man and he like starts hitting
on the school teacher and stuff."
Holland's Spider-Man: Far From Home co-star
Zendaya, who plays Michelle "MJ" Jones in
the current Spider-Man film series, was keen
on the idea.
"I would love to see Hugh Jackman try to be
Peter Parker!"
"What is that?
What are you doing?"
'He's doing his Wolverine thing."
"Yeah."
For those unfamiliar with Ultimate Spider-Man,
the issues Holland is referring to are Ultimate
Spider-Man #66 and #67 from 2004.
The story was also loosely adapted into an
episode of Disney XD's Ultimate Spider-Man
cartoon series in 2012.
“This mask smells."
"You complete me."
Issue #66 sees Peter Parker and the powerful
mutant Wolverine coming together after a "bizarre
occurrence" ties them to each other.
The two heroes try to decode the mystery,
and all the while their personal lives begin
to unravel.
Together, #66 and #67 tell a classic Freaky
Friday-type body swap tale; or, as Marvel's
official description of #67 puts it,
"Wolverine and Spider-Man have always been
in each other's faces.
Today they're in each other's bodies!"
"Oh my God!"
As Holland explained, Ultimate Spider-Man
#66 sees Peter waking up and not recognizing
anything in his house.
In his hotel room, Wolverine is experiencing
the same confusion: he doesn't know who he
is and is startled by his appearance.
While telling Mary Jane Watson that he really
doesn't want to go to school, Peter gets a
phone call from Wolverine.
Their conversation leads to the big revelation:
they've swapped bodies.
Peter and Wolverine meet at school, where
Wolverine (in Peter's body) is skipping class.
When Peter and Wolverine are about to leave,
Peter (in Wolverine's body) heads toward a
car chase, which leads to an unfortunate event
involving an enormous truck.
Ultimate Spider-Man #67 picks right up where
#66 left off, and follows Peter and Wolverine
as they try to figure out a way to reverse
the body swap.
After a string of hilarious mishaps, fellow
X-Men member Jean Grey saves the day in a
hilarious twist.
Holland's chat with Comics Explained caught
the attention of Brian Michael Bendis, the
writer behind the Peter Parker and Wolverine
body swap story.
Bendis retweeted a video clip of the interview,
adding in the caption,
"EVERYone else can see this too, right?"
When it comes to a potential body swap movie
with Spider-Man and Wolverine, it isn't so
much a question of whether it can happen but
rather a case of whether Marvel Studios would
want to do it.
Now that the Walt Disney Company owns the
majority of 20th Century Fox's assets, Wolverine
and the rest of the X-Men squad are property
of the Mouse House - and, more specifically,
Marvel Studios.
Though Marvel's head honcho Kevin Feige has
mentioned that it will be "a handful of years"
before the Disney-Fox merger would impact
the MCU, he is looking to recast Wolverine
with a younger actor when the studio inevitably
reboots the X-Men team.
It's only a matter of time before fans witness
a new Wolverine entering the MCU, where Holland's
Spider-Man is already a major player.
Will the two cross paths and swap bodies for
a big-screen feature sometime in the future?
Never say never.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.